Olivia Pratt corbell's Father John Pratt
he had his statement read out on his
behalf he said I want you to know that
you have changed my life and my family's
life forever I have nightmares about how
she died and the nightmares won't go
away I am heartbroken sometimes I just
want to end it so that I can be with
Olivia again I want to visit Olivia and
I sometimes sit outside the cemetery but
I can't go in because if I do it will
all seem too real Mr Pratt was in court
sitting watching his statement be read
out the statement went on to say you
have denied my beautiful girl Olivia her
future I will never see her on her
wedding day and walk her down the aisle
and see her grow into the beautiful
woman she was destined to become we have
been robbed of her future because of you
she will always be forever nine
Olivia's sister her older sister stood
up in court earlier to read her
statement herself she spoke from the
witness box uh
a sister is Chloe Corbell she said this
Olivia was the best friend I had always
wanted we were so close as I was not
only her big sister but I'd look after
her when our mum was working
Olivia believed what was mine was also
hers I'd often look for something and
not be able to find it it'd turn up the
next day in her makeup bag or in one of
her drawers
Chloe said the day Olivia was killed was
the worst of her life she said not only
did I lose my baby sister but I lost my
best friend
when I was told she had passed away I
felt as though my heart stopped beating
Chloe said she and her family are living
in a real life tragedy because of
selfish people thinking it's okay to
carry guns
Chloe Corbell went on to say I miss my
baby sister and I miss my best friend
all the things we should be doing
shopping together laughing together and
making memories of Chloe Corbell just a
teenager standing up in that witness box
this afternoon to deliver that statement
on behalf of herself her family and her
little sister Olivia
well Olivia's mom Cheryl Corbell stood
up and read out her statement as well
she said that her nine-year-old was
loved by everyone and never stopped
talking
um Cheryl core Bell in tears as she
explained that Olivia was due to cut her
hair to donate it to sick children but
was killed just five days before her
appointment uh Cheryl Corbell says I
just miss hearing her voice I would give
anything in the world to have her
chatting to me Cheryl explained how the
alarm goes off in their house at 7 30 in
the morning every day it's the time that
she used to get up with Olivia and the
day then goes by in a blur by 2 30. she
says she is conditioned to be going on
the school run but that is something she
says she will never be able to do again
a cherical bell saying this happened in
our home where we felt safe she added
that they were allowed to return to the
house after the police investigation and
it was like time Stood Still
Cheryl Corbell saying I was not able to
do CPR
on Olivia because of my injury um you
may remember that the bullet that
fatally
wounded young Olivia first went through
the wrist of her mother
um Cheryl Cobell saying I wasn't able to
do CPR because of that injury I felt
helpless my worst nightmare was being
separated from Liv and not being with
her when she needed me the most I cannot
get my head around how Cashman continued
to shoot after he heard the screams that
man set out to do a job and he didn't
care about anyone else or who got in the
way
Olivia's mom's saying it is so hard to
go back to the area where she grew up
and where she raised her three children
they've moved into a new house which she
said was difficult for the whole family
I cannot even think about revealeding
our lives without her she said
she went on to explain that while the
trial has been on her Nan was admitted
to hospital and she passed away last
night
Cheryl Corbell saying that she believed
her name was holding on to hear that
Thomas Cashman had been found guilty
she went on to describe Olivia as her
Shadow and ended her statement by saying
her family will love her endlessly